all right I want to announce some new
tour dates for you guys okay I want to
announce these tour dates right now
Wednesday March 22nd we have a new show
added uh for Houston
it's a new venue at the Bayou Music
Center down there that's March 22nd
Wednesday at 8 pm
um and then we're going back to Boston
we're coming back for another week March
31st
uh at the Hampton Beach Casino ballroom
that one's in Hampton Beach New
Hampshire
um
that's uh Friday and then Saturday we
will be uh in Medford Massachusetts
Saturday April 1st now which is just
right outside of Boston
um on April 1st and uh Sunday May 14th
uh we have the Beacon Theater in New
York
City
and then uh Friday July 7th we have now
added the Encore Theater another Show in
Las Vegas that is the day before the UFC
fights if you were going there for UFC
um you can come to the show the day
before
and all those tickets is available at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r uh make sure you're going
through there to get tickets and thank
you so much uh for the support out there
in the world
what's up guys my name is Theo I'm a
human being
um
happy just checking in about life right
now uh
what's been going on recently
um
I've been feeling pretty good recently
you know uh honestly
it's a little scary
you know I get a little scared sometimes
when uh
I think when things are going well or
when things are feeling good
um
it's like you know I I kind of
I don't know how to handle it
uh I think there's a little part of me
that feels like oh you well you don't
deserve it or there's it's not
something's wrong I think I'm just so
used to the feelings inside of me over
the years not being
uh good ones
that I'm that those are the footprints I
still
I'm those are the footprints I I
continue to walk in
you know
and so only recently if I felt like I'm
kind of making some new shapes in the
mud
man things are kind of going okay
um
and yeah it's just such a foreign it
just been foreign to my lifet to feel
okay
it's been foreign to me
um
and sometimes there's a part of me that
doesn't want to that doesn't want to be
it doesn't that doesn't want to feel
okay
if I'm real honest um
there's a part of me that always wants
to have something wrong
to be able to
look at the world
or look at myself
or look at my past and
say I told you so
you know
um
so it's
it's scary almost to be like I think
everything's kind of okay
because it feels kind of new
um
but yeah I just I just wanted to kind of
check in uh
with some of just some you know I like
feelings I like
most of my life I really have been kind
of addicted to my own feelings I realize
you know I even notice that when I go to
like these recovery meetings and stuff
I'll be in there and people are talking
about uh being addicted to a drug or an
alcohol or something
over over the years I've been addicted a
lot of times to my own feelings
it's like I started having a feeling and
then I'll start sipping off that [__]
you know I start feeling one way and
then I'll I'll buy an eight ball of my
own feelings almost I'm like well I'm
gonna better do a couple grams of this
depression
I better do a couple uh lines if I'm not
enough you know I can get I can get
that that my feelings become almost the
drug that I'm using
I don't know if that makes any sense uh
and that's okay if it doesn't I'm just
I'm just saying what's going on
um
but what's up nice to see you guys nice
to be a part of your life today
um
I'm happy to be alive uh I miss my
brother I've been thinking about him a
lot recently he's alive I just miss him
um
what else ah
I went to the Super Bowl the other day
which
I can't even believe I'm just saying
that so casually
but dang I you know I went to the damn
Super Bowl
uh which was fine it was good it's
almost a little
you get you know you go to the Super
Bowl
and it's such a business it's such a
corporate deal
you know everybody there is you know
smells like they're a briefcase or you
know has a um
business account or something
you know or is you know everybody claims
they're friends with like uh
but you know uh Puff Daddy or Jeff
Gordon or some [__] or Guy Fieri
everybody's like oh you know I got
you know I got seven autographed uh
spatulas from Guy Fieri like all right
well
chill out you know big daddy or whatever
but it's like
uh there's a lot it's it just feels like
a real businessy event so much so that
you almost feel bad for the players on
the field
because it doesn't seem like it's about
the game that much
they stop in the game every 30 seconds
they got they're selling a toaster
they're selling a Nintendo you know they
got they put a new uh hearing aid and
you know in big Ricky the uh
offensive top you know
um tackle and they're you know look at
Ricky you know Ricky hears his dog for
the first time or whatever
you know Ricky hears a uh someone open a
Lunchable for the first time ever
you ever hear you ever see those videos
they'll be like uh
uh you know uh disabled veteran here's
um
a wolf howl
or you know or Native American uh
disabled Native American here's wolf
howl for the first time
and they'll have a ah
they'll have a disabled uh n a out there
and he's all feathered out or something
he's washing his feet or something and
he doesn't know what's going on and then
they put that earpiece in him and then
they show the [__] wolf
and then the guy like looks up for the
first time you know
and probably starts jerking off I mean
if I I gotta if I'm
this is no judgment but if I'm if I've
never heard anything my whole life and I
hear a [__] wolf Set It Off dog
I mean you got a damn
you got a pretty you gotta come soon I
feel like
how I mean that's as native and natural
as you can get
um
but anyway yeah it was just very
corporate you know every 30 seconds
they're stopping it and selling
something and it just gets real
corporate to the point you're like you
almost it's all her it's hard even
pay attention to the game there's so
much going on uh but I felt grateful to
be able to go and have that experience I
went down there with um
with raising canes with some of them
Louisiana boys
so that was very exciting oh I mean I
just can't believe I got to go to the
dang Super Bowl I was sitting there and
Caleb Presley was there and you know I'm
a fan of his and
um
and it was just interesting
you know and just like dude I can't
believe I'm at the Super Bowl
you know it was just I don't know kind
of blew my own mind
oh but here was the thing that happened
that made the weekend amazing uh
I got to meet Drew Brees man
I got to meet Drew Brees and
I was over there with David Spades and
y'all know David Spades okay one of my
heroes and all one of America's Heroes
I mean he's the damn Davy Crockett of
humor
um
and he invited me over to a party he was
a fundraiser
they're raising funds and
um so we go there and it's nice there's
like
there's like rich people and somebody's
somebody was like being real rich and
then somebody was next to him and they
were
you know
they started crying and the other
person's like don't cry you're rich you
know so people were just being [__]
rich in this place and
um
and so we walk up and Blake Shelton is
there
and I like Blake Shelton man I like
Blake Shelton
um
he is an Oklahoma guy
and he uh you know he just sings and
he's comfortable man and I've met him
before
and uh and I I like him I like him
so anyway we walk up Blake Shelton is
playing it's like it's like the part in
the evening at a party where somebody is
playing music so everybody kind of FS to
be quiet
and we walk up and there's a guy Steve
Mariucci okay he's a uh coach
he's a coach and I want to say he's
Italian I'm not trying to be racial or
anything but
That's Italian you know and he looks
Italian you know he looks like if you if
you tickle him he'll [__] just he'll
tell you all the ingredients of a
cannoli even if he doesn't want to you
know he just has that that look to him
and
I walk up and he Steve Mariucci is
talking to Drew Brees
and I've had dreams in my life my head
where I'm like how do you meet do you
ever meet Drew Brees does God want you
to ever meet Drew Brees
you know does Mother Nature is there
ever another flood and
one of y'all gets flooded right up next
to the other one and you get to finally
meet
um
and so there he is and I would and and
so when you're with David Spade David
Spade can kind of just go up to anybody
and like be like
and people are like happy about it so
I'm just kind of Milling around in the
distance being like
hey look at David Spade and um
and so anyway he walks the Spade walks
up and I just kind of like in his shadow
like kind of there but hiding but trying
to be like confident like okay how do I
how do I walk up to Drew Brees you know
do I look like uh
do I look right at him do I kind of look
you know at the moon like what you know
how do you do it do I you know put my
shoulders even do I kind of like be like
one shoulder is heavier
do I
what do I do you know and I was nervous
man and so
David kind of starts joking and they're
both excited to see the spade and
they're talking to him and I'm right
there and I know at some point it's
coming around
that
Spade is going to introduce me so I'm
like what uh you know how do I how do I
look when he's like hey this is the and
I'm like do I smile do I
so I don't know what to do so I open my
mouth right which is insane I think
that's an insane
you know you're me okay I got his mouth
open and then
I put both hands out like this
like if you know if you ask somebody how
long is something they say oh about
one foot long
that's what I did he like
David introduced me to each guy and I
it was almost like you had given
somebody
uh it was almost like that guy maybe in
what's the sport Maybe
uh
uh is that
rugby or Cricket when the guy does
that you know anyway so I did two hands
died two hands shaped Mariucci and
and Breeze and so out the gate I'm like
oh God this you know I'm not doing that
good
hey I'm not doing good you know and I
started just kind of praying for myself
um
which you're not supposed to do I know
that you know you're supposed to pray
for others uh but I did I I needed I
needed it and I was right there and I'm
like what do you say when do you say
something do you say anything who are
you are you someone that says something
soon or are you not
do you just listen do you laugh how loud
do you laugh do you laugh you don't want
to sound like a fake you know
uh so anyway I'm just being alive
and um
and Breeze is dialed in bro when you're
talking to him
he's like you can see in his eye bro he
could play for I think another
I think he could play for another 20
months in the NFL
well
he's just he's so locked in like you're
talking to him and you can see he's
watching like where the waiters and the
bus boys are going you know he can see
the
um you know that one of the waiters is
running an out route to go on a smoke
break he can see that the busboy did a
curl but you know short of the sticks
you can I mean he's like
he's caught you know he's got an audible
he's got Colston going over there's
everything he's he's monitoring
everything
while you're there talking to him he is
dialed in
he is dialed into life
and you don't even know if Drew Brees
blinks that's how my he he blinks when
you blink
he sees you blink so that's when he
that's when he blinks he ain't missing a
moment
he's locked in
and it was interesting because
um I asked him I said hey did you guys
ever play against each other him and um
Mariucci right
and uh
and Brees was like yeah we sure did and
if he rattled off the date he rattled
off the score
um
and you could just I mean he is just an
anthology
of uh
of precision
is kind of how I would describe him as
much as I got to you know I I I got to
talk with them for maybe about 10
minutes
total
and maybe 90 seconds I could kind of
feel my arms and legs uh while I was
doing it
so a lot of time I was just pretending
to you know have a stable
um
uh what's it called when they oh pulse
so anyway that's a lot about Drew Brees
but
um we're gonna take some calls that came
in from you guys
um
what else I'm going to
I got to me oh I got to meet I know I'm
name dropping man but I just was so like
uh George Kittle
and I'd seen like videos George Kittle
and but he there's that
it's like
it's a me
yeah there is
uh
I don't even know
it's you got it's George Kittle
is um he is an interesting guy he's got
his energy he shows up at a level where
you're like oh I didn't know they had
this level
you know
um
but he was very kind I'm friends with
his sister Emma uh kiddo who is a yoga
instructor and she's uh really
incredible and uh she taught me yoga in
Nashville
and um so it was just really great I got
to meet uh their whole family
um yeah we're gonna get into some calls
we got the kai The Hitchhiker uh we're
gonna talk to the attorney about that
finally
um I got served some papers the other
day I mean a man came and served me
papers so we're going to get into that
we're going to listen to some of you
guys calls
um I want to let you know that manscape
is now selling beard products
that's right they've gone from waist to
face to help you replace that bulky
razor with their brand new beard hedger
Pro kit
this kid is about to change your life
has made it easier than ever to craft
your signature look you can really just
just just Vincent Van glorify your face
no more drawers full of 20 different
guards that's right the trimmer has a
titanium coated t-blade that is tough on
here but smooth on your face
they'll do it the beard hedger it's a
juggernaut of fixing faces
uh it has a rotary wheel that gives you
20 hair cutting lengths all with one
guard so no more mess
the pro beard kit also comes with three
free gifts a beard brush comb and
scissors to ensure your beard is ready
to impress so get 20 off in free
shipping with our code Theo at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use our
code t-h-e-o the manscaped beard hedger
Pro kit the premier solution to face
grooming this new year you've got goals
you've got goals we've got goals
and factor is here to help you achieve
every one of them fuel up fast with
ready to eat nutritious meals delivered
straight to your door leaving you time
and energy to tackle everything on your
to-do list achieve and maintain your
2023 goals with Factor get America's
number one ready to eat meal kit and
start saving time eating well and living
your best year yet
with 34 Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly options there's always something
new to try whether it's keto calorie
smart vegan and veggie or Protein Plus
uh Factor can handle it they've got it
for you head to factormeals.com
Theo five zero that's t-h-e-o number
five number zero and use code theo50
Theo five zero again to get 50 off your
first box that's code Theo five zero at
factormeals.com
Theo five zero to get 50 off your first
box you know what's funny sometimes I
don't I get on here and I don't know
what to tell you about
I don't know what to share with you I
don't know what to
um
you know the whole time I was talking to
Drew Brees I could see him just
he was always every now and then he
would glance in the distance and just
see if Deborah Henderson was open
that's all that's all I'm gonna say
about that
um the news man let's get into a little
bit of news the Ohio uh train derailment
a train derailment in East Palestine
Ohio prompted an array of false and
misleading claims on social media you
know that
um
a Norfolk Southern Train left the tracks
while traveling from Madison Illinois to
Conway Pennsylvania
uh
residents ordered to evacuate
and evacuation is hard
it seems like easier you get in your car
truck or camper and drive
but where do you go traffic is full
you know if you don't have gas already
then you have to go wait for gas first
so then you're at the pump you're
pumping gas and you're huffing gas
because the the atmosphere is filled
with it
and then there's all kind of rumors that
you know that how it got burned off some
people say that the government showed up
and did it some people say there were
just uh you know a couple damn Browns
fans or or uh Steelers fans firing
um Fireworks into it and [__] and blew
it all up I mean
you can't keep a gas in the air
you know in some of these areas without
somebody liking it you know even if
you're at a party and you fart somebody
will run over there and light it if
you're in Cleveland
I mean who you know who we kidding
you know
so
I'm not shocked that it got lit up I
think a lot of people are are freaked
out they had a man yelling
at the sky
I'll tell you this the whole thing was
better than any M Night Shyamalan movie
I've seen in [__] 10 years
has anybody been given more
opportunities than that guy
um then you have all these people with
their home values now they're scared
they have no equity in their homes but
just because of the fear of this
and you don't know you know we live in a
space now where we expect things to be
done quickly we're so you you see
something on the Internet you see okay
this should be solved right now
and in some ways it should there should
be like task force should be sent to
help you know there should be plans in
place for things
um but the speed of life is not the same
as the speed of the internet
the speed of social media
you know it's easy for somebody to like
help these people
right and I even do it on Twitter the
other day I shared something it was like
where are the
uh like Transportation head of
Transportation Where is the Norfolk
Southern people like just trying to
I guess I'm just rattling the cage
but yeah you wonder like how how do
these people start to feel okay
when they go to like a town hall meeting
and they're just yelling at a mayor and
he doesn't know
um
but it's scary you know the rail system
has been
we've done a horrible job in America of
taking care of our rail system of taking
care of our postal system
[Music]
dude I would rather give my [__] dude
more people the rail system first of all
more people are going on
Hogwarts train than on
any Amtrak
that's a fact more people are lining up
for Hogwarts
so I don't know it's just heartbreaking
man you see that out there these people
got derailed and a lady it says right
here throwing Rock and water
and she looks insane this lady
and she's saying look at all the
chemicals in the water
yeah but that's just damn water too lady
I mean I know it's bad over there if
you're over there hit the hotline let us
know 985-664-9503
um
but I think a lot of This falls back on
do you feel like your country cares
anymore do you feel like I think we live
we're living we're getting into a space
where people do not feel supported by
their country they don't feel like
there's this
they're always used to feel like this
texture behind us that our country was
unified and supporting us and looking
out for the the regular man and woman oh
and and the child who was getting a pail
of clean water in East Palestine
as opposed to the big business you know
um
big chloride or whoever spilled all this
[__]
and then now you got a lady
and the water looks good
look at it it's all in the bottom of the
creek bed
yeah
I mean you don't know also they could
have we don't know you don't know a
video somebody this thing could be right
outside of a Pep Boys and they've been
spilling [__] back in there for years
I'm not denying it I'm just saying that
who knows but yeah
there'll be shrimp coming out of here
probably a decade from now wearing a
[__] Top Hat you'll have a you know
in a neck brace it's all going to be bad
newborn babies come out with [__] you
know in with neck braces on their knees
it's gonna who knows
who knows what's going to happen
a lot of you know they're gonna have a
lot of young women that look like Rob
Gronkowski probably who know we don't
know
but uh we're there with you in spirit
what else can we be that's all we can be
right now
um
all right as some of you guys know uh uh
um Kai The Hitchhiker
who is a notorious
um inner figure in entertainment I guess
um he's a homeless
uh or not homeless he's a vagabond he is
a uh Tumbleweed with a
um with a with a bit of violence that
surrounds him that's all I'll say uh
he filed a lawsuit against me
for a tick tock clip that was put up or
Instagram clip
um that I didn't create that I shared
and uh I wanted to talk with um my buddy
Dan Morgan over at the Morgan Morgan
attorney firm
um
at the Morgan Morgan law firm and see uh
what the deal was so let's let's make
that call now if we can
hello this is Dan hey Dan man what's up
bud it's Theo
hey man what's going on uh well I sent
you you know I got served um I want to
talk about the kai the uh hitchhiker
thing
yeah yeah for sure I got those documents
so I reviewed them actually over the
weekend yeah man is so is it a real uh
is it a real thing like is it
I'm just I guess I'm kind of
I don't know you know I I guess I'm
scared I'm yeah I'm scared about I don't
know what to do
it it is real in the sense that he did
file it he did I make some claims he's
currently incarcerated I believe in New
Jersey it seemed but it kind of
learn the law a little bit and drafted
up this complaint so it is an actual
complaint that they get served in
federal court
um you know as far as the merits to it I
don't think there's much there I think
emotion uh to the submissive was kind of
cleaning up for you
okay
um so what do I uh how what is he asking
for
so he's making some some pretty
egregious claims in there I mean he goes
into all there's a lot of TMI really
about his other cases and his other
these other legal trouble that's going
on but then he pretty much does some
type of algebraic equation that that
gets to a demand request somewhere
around 30 million dollars
I think it's around 20 29 750
000 something around those damages
from YouTube and Instagram views what do
I do
I must have to work I mean do I have to
work forever or what
I mean it sounds like he's claiming
you've already made this money so the
question is what have you done with all
that money
dude what is he talking about dude I
[__] have a I drive a Ford Ranger
he's saying you made all this money off
using this uh this deep fake of him
you've stolen his uh his Valor so to
speak I didn't make it his name
you're all good yeah he has this whole
outlandish theory that you have a a fake
identity daughter account where you made
this and then repurpose it to then to
then uh post on your YouTube and without
having to be the point person that he
could go after wow
it's like a 30 page Manifesto complaint
he he's he's doctored up from uh
so I'm just federal penitentiary
so is this so so what is when do I what
how long do when do I need to when do I
need to do something so it looks like
you got like a he served about eight
days ago or so like uh you got 21 days
per per federal civil procedure so you
know just just an answer pretty much
saying you know this is a bogus
also the motion to dismiss and a judge
should just just throw it out for you
but you do have to kind of make sure you
get those timelines interest there could
be a default judgment where
old cow could get a check from steel for
30 million well he's never who's I don't
know where he even cash it yeah that's a
thing
might take it
um okay so what do do you does uh does
y'all's Law Firm help with that or is
that something I need to do
that's something that I can help you get
get to the right person to do you know
we're we're more a plaintiff's type firm
we don't really do this defense work but
I can definitely get you the right hands
out there with California okay uh
Federal turn to get this thing cleaned
up for you okay Jesus dude yeah I mean I
I
um is this is this going to be like a
thing that happens in the world because
this was a uh deep fake that I didn't
have anything to do with I mean
obviously I repurposed it and put it out
and I think it I thought it was funny
and entertaining so I don't know if
there is some responsibility there I
don't know
exactly and when you kind of sent this
over to me I kind of started doing some
research and it's obviously that's
popping up more and more now with
technology getting as it is and you just
really put in any video with any picture
and it turns it out but you know pretty
much it falls under some copyright
exceptions where where it's parity it's
an Ultimate Defense so
um you know it's art it's parody it's
not meant to be real you know there's
some protections out there especially
like political figures and revenge porn
stuff like that where there's been laws
that have been put put into place for
deep fakes but as far as you know this
type of stuff is really it's just parody
where where there's no real recourse or
damages that can be assessed for it wow
it's interesting because it that's gonna
I mean with with CGI and that sort of
this kind of thing if this is going to
be probably a growing field yeah
oh let's pop it up yeah because I mean
they got you know when the political
race is around they'll just take the
whatever party they don't like and just
have them saying some Outlanders you
know outlandish Comics like you know
crazy stances and they put it out there
on YouTube and it gets retweeted and
they say you know it's become fact how I
mean how do we
what does the future hold
yeah I mean even now it's like it's I
mean the videos are getting better and
better the now they even have it where
you can type in
you know manifestos are lyrics and it
will spit it out in the person's voice
too so it doesn't even have to be a
recording them saying this is you know
it's copying of their vocals now and
spitting it out yeah yeah we just been
talking about some of that recently that
chat GPT I think it's called and when
that merges with like Holograms or deep
fakes it's gonna get
I mean it's gonna get really strange you
know I I saw a thing a while back where
they had so much footage and um audio of
Joe Rogan that they could make him have
they could have audio of him now saying
absolutely almost anything in the world
oh exactly yeah and that that's how they
have all these politicians not to make
the speeches you know three speeches a
day they're just downloaded and all he
said hey let's make them say you know
listen to like other like power started
the past it would take them you know
years to chop up something to have it
even not even something else you just
type it into a into a chat bot and it
spits it out in 30 seconds yeah man I
mean all we cared about was make them
say
um
and it's just changed so much
um is this is this gonna be a field that
you guys will cover a lot uh at Shell's
Law Firm or is this
I mean if there was a there was damages
against the natural plaintiff or if
there was some real harm that was done
and you know and something came from it
you would definitely look look into it
um but as far as just these celebrities
having deep fakes made and stuff like
that you know it's probably something
we're going to stay away and just see
how the the law evolves around it amen
dude thanks so much man I appreciate it
bro it's definitely been spooky and yeah
the guy came up and served the papers
and I thought it was like a Jew like a
I don't want to say like a homeless dude
not home I mean he was like yeah they're
sneaky those process servers get sneaky
with it bro I thought it was like kind
of a game like kind of a dude who was
being kind of homoerotic or something
because he kind of just hit an audience
but it was hitting on you I mean he just
like kind of moseyed up I thought he'd
written me a poem or something and then
uh yeah and then he hit me with that and
he kind of like he didn't give like yeah
yeah it kind of like it was just I don't
know bro but I'm trying to meet a wife
boom it was just surprising I'd never
really been served any papers I'd seen
it happen a lot but I'd never got them
myself so it was almost kind of nice
dude and it was almost like a valentine
in a weird way right yeah someone was
thinking about you yeah yeah that's true
these days that's nice uh Dan Morgan
thanks so much man I appreciate it
brother
any time man I'm always call away yeah
thank you so much dude uh I'll chat with
you soon
all right sounds good my man all right
peace if you have a question about a
legal issue you have a
um something that you think they might
be able to help with uh the least I can
do for that uh for the help there is um
to put their information uh below
you know it's scary it's scary when
something comes along or when uh there's
something in the legal realm and you
don't know what to do you know this that
can be spooky
okay
let's get into some calls if we can
uh here we go as always the hotline is
985-664-9503
[Music]
yo Theo my name is B rap I'm out here in
Indiana you know home of the math
dwap thank you for calling brother
onward oh [__] cord
and uh you know I just had a question
man
so I got a friend and he's my best
friend one of my best friends we started
became friends a few years ago
man he's been cheating on his girlfriend
and
I don't really like any of that and I
told him man
I need I'm gonna need to tell your
girlfriend if you're cheating on her man
I'll give you a week to tell her
man that week went by and I told him if
I'm married to tell your girl he's like
man don't worry about it we're not
getting broken up
so you know like what do I do in that
situation like I don't want to tell his
girlfriend because he's my homie but at
the same time I hate cheaters because my
dad cheated on my mom back in the day
and you know that [__] really [__] me
up and I've been cheated on so
meth or corn baby
meth or corn
it's a lifelong question brother I feel
you I think you gotta you can definitely
say to your buddy hey
not cool to cheat on this gal I don't
know if you go tell the gal though
that's a little bit snitchy that's a
little bit like I'm gonna take
responsibility
um you know it's not that's not your
world
um
yeah
so I I mean it's your world but it's not
I don't know that to me feels like
you're trying to control too much of
things
now maybe if it goes on for a lot you
know I it's so tough to know but I feel
like that's a little bit uh more of a
thing you take up with your boy that's
what you do you take it up with your boy
hey man
I don't think this is a good thing
you know I wish you wouldn't do this
um
but then also I mean who know you know
it's tough if you may have a feeling for
that girl
but I don't know if that's the way to go
about it I would start with your boy man
I would just say it again and then if
you put a week on him and you didn't do
nothing then you're not even really
about it anyway
so if you're going to be about it be
about it
you know
so I would say man I can't you know if
you're gonna be uh that's not the vibe I
like to put out there it's not something
I want to be associated with
then that's fair but then you gotta
stand by that with them if you just tell
them every week hey man don't be
cheating or I'm out of here and then you
stick around
you know
then and then you going to tell her then
you you ain't even you ain't even do
nothing
so praise God baby thank you for calling
that's what I suggest also I don't know
a thing man
you know I've been a cheater I've
cheated on people and
I don't know it's [__] it is no it's
no way to treat somebody
I know that
um
but praise God baby
let's see what else we got
um
all right let's take this call as always
the hotline is 985-664-950
three
hey Theo
um I'm calling I had I work in a uh
Learning Center
and that's a school baby that's a school
onward
past few weeks I've been having
there's just been
I worked with special ed kids and uh you
know it's
oh yeah
I know what you're talking about brother
I was in special ed baby
let's hear more it's it's a job it gets
stuff done but recently there's been a
kid named James he has autism and
uh recently he's been trying to
uh
sexually assault me
that adds up baby oh
yeah
I mean I feel like if somebody
I don't know how to say this
first of all a lot of people named James
have
you know
they're chisholmed out
and that's
you could draw a damn graph of that
and uh
and it would check out
but
uh what are we talking about
um
let me play it again
recently there's been a kid named James
who has autism and
uh recently he's been trying to
uh
sexually assault me
yeah well look if people have autism
they're going to want to [__] they want
to get out that damn
you know
they want to [__] burp that little
nut wand baby
you know
they I mean
sometimes you just I feel if you ever
just been so just
you just want to spray on something
so I can't even if I had autism I'd
if you know
if I had fully documented autism
I would be I'd spray on half the things
in town probably let's hear more
and you know I don't really care but
it's more frightening for the other
students yes
and
the thing is you know
I know they can't help it and stuff but
every time he does it he just has this
look in his eyes oh yeah this lustful
evil look
well they say if uh
they say if the devil's got your nuts
he's got your eyes
laughs
because the eyes are just the nuts of
the face
so
yeah the feeling you have in your nuts
is always the feeling that you have in
your eyes
go punch somebody in the nuts
and look in their eyes
same pain baby
and yeah look it's tough man look
first of all I command you for being out
there and being on the front lines of um
of special ed
you know
uh let's hear more almost like he knows
what he's doing and if he knows that
it's wrong and he'll be you know he'll
be running around he'll be stop that
James stop it James please stop and you
know you'll be helicopter in it and it's
just it's scary
and we're a little
we're a little afraid for our safety
well hopeless don't get crazy
the you know
I mean you know you don't have to be
afraid for your safety though you gotta
you know you got a mentally unwell fella
just you know running around trying you
know
I mean he's probably in heat have you
thought about that it's spring baby it's
almost spring it's gonna be spring in a
few months
so you don't know what
you know and if somebody's autism they
might be off by a month or two and their
genetics easily
you can easily see that that's [__]
that's that DNA leap year homie if you
got autism
so
yeah dude it's springtime that Fella's
in heat
that's what you're getting there
James is in heat man
I'd get him a little bust post over in
the corner
get a little pair of uh
um
get you a half of a mannequin and put
some damn uh
uh Daisy Dukes on it that's what I would
do
and put that thing you know put a candle
or two in a closet and let him get in
there and pump on it
you know you have to have a plan
but if you're just yelling stop it James
and he's out there just you know
he's tugging on that little spunk
whisker that's stop it James isn't gonna
help
you know you're not a damn crossing
guard brother
or
hit him with some Narcan brother
that'll shut anybody down
you know they don't like to put all the
different you know uses or whatever on
the thing but
if I got a you know somebody in my area
and they're over there splurging that
little uh that little splash Hammer
right in front of me
I'll just damn hit him with that Narcan
baby
you know let the Lord sort them out
praise God babe let's hear a little bit
more and thank you for the call man I'm
sorry that you're having a deal with
some of this and I'm almost afraid of
some students because
we found it we found a collection of
uh almost like a booger collection but
it was
it was other people's pictures that he
took from under a stairwell
so
but we've been working on stuff I don't
know what to do with him well he might
be damn an artist brother you can't you
know it sounds like he's an artist
so don't condemn him for that
um you know I know they can't help it
but every time I every time I look into
the eyes he's just he's just painting
with that lustful um he'll smirk when he
does it too it's like he knows what he's
doing that's heat brother he's in heat
and that's somebody in heat and so I
think at that point you got to do prayer
you gotta
you gotta consider Narcan but I would do
prayer first
and um
and yeah and look I'll just commend you
man for being there
and being there on the front lines of
autism
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
give online therapy a try at
betterhelp.com Theo and get on your way
to being your best self that's right
when you're at your best you can do
great things you could build something
new or create something new you can feel
comfortable enough to love somebody or
or love yourself maybe even
you can do all of that
but sometimes life gets you bogged down
and you may feel overwhelmed or like
you're not showing up in the way you
want to that happens
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
and better help
can connect you with that therapist if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
it's convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online it's better help just
fill out a brief questionnaire to get
matched with a licensed therapist and
switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge
uh if you want to live a more empowered
life therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
Theo today to get 10 off your first
month that's better h-e-l-p
uh.com slash Theo betterhelp.com Theo
uh let's hear some more what else came
in man I was feeling
had a couple comedy sets last night we
had some sets I forgot to tell you down
in Louisiana that was it was fun a
couple of them the crowds were a little
Rowdy but uh the ones that weren't my
God they were awesome
man they were awesome shows
I'm so thankful it was so just cool to
go through Louisiana and we're over
there you know
and we went to Shreveport that play this
it went out of business
I mean they had it was just
they had a building there I was walking
on the street a building asked me for
forty dollars
so
all right let's hear uh this call that
came in right here
hey Theo
I want to hear your opinion about
something that happened to me at work
recently uh
to give you a little background on me I
grew up with a gay mom
and she had a meth addiction my
brother's gay my niece is a bisexual
transgender woman and a polyamorous
relationships damn
you're living in a dang Skittle Bowl
baby
Amen brother onward
I'm not against any of it honestly
um same bro
same baby
I want people to be true themselves you
know but
it's all fun and games man until your
boss
who's the HR manager texts you unwanted
propositions
had a chili cook-off at work
oh yeah
yeah a lot of times food can be a
gateway drug to all
homosexuality
let's hear more
anyway
you near about the same age and uh
things are for sure different than when
we grew up
and with the current climate
how do you think I should approach this
situation
you know Pro well just because
somebody's hitting on you
yeah I think if you are gay or
considering gay
and let me repeat that if you are gay or
considering gay then you approach this
man return them go do it
do the chili do the chili with him
that's fine nobody's you know
I mean you're probably most your family
is gay
it sounds like it you know anybody that
even stops by y'all's house ends up gay
to be honest from what you said so you
could easily be gay dude you might be
you might not even be lonely you might
just be gay and be
just gaying around
bothering women
I'm not saying that but it could be
happening
um but I don't think you need to feel a
pressure because of the way the climate
is to return uh
any homo erada homo eroticism
you know you don't have to do anything
like that
just because of the climate you don't
want you know just because there's a lot
of gay stuff happening you have to you
know do that
um
but also innately some of these chili
cook-off circles it's a hotbed for gay
activity
you know it's a lot of men it's all men
doing it they're wearing aprons you see
a lot of that uh cutting onions one of
them's tearing up one of them comes over
what's up what's up what's up Henry
what's wrong
nothing's [__] wrong dude
he's got there with the damn Devil's
vegetables
that's what it is I mean onions I said
you know my God
it's the Nicholas Sparks of [__]
vegetables
I mean when do we when do we shut that
[__] down
just but yeah that whole the whole thing
with the chili cook-off
it's a hotbed for gay men to sneak in
and you know hit you with that little
shishito pepper
you know
and just hit you with that little uh
you know like just try to get you to sip
off that little uh that little batter
fountain
off a little Bobby's little fondue
railing you know you know what I'm
talking about weiner
so uh yeah I think just take care of
yourself either way but also if you you
know it may you might be reading
yourself wrong here's what I would do I
would get seven or eight of your friends
I would ask them all
am I gay
do you think or on a scale of one to ten
don't even go all this you know put get
yourself a number and then walk out into
the world and know
thank you for the call man I love you
and we all love you
um what else do we have here
what's going on
it's Mike and uh it's that Urban
gentleman what's up Mike baby Urban Mike
baby welcome baby praise God Son beige
gang
out of South Florida
um
so uh I was adopted at Birth man and uh
you know I don't know anybody from my
you know my biological side and uh I
decided to do some searching and I found
my uh
I found my mother on Facebook and I
found uh I found some bad news she's uh
she's locked up right now up North
for a while
for quite a while but um
I did uh I decided to message her
yesterday man I finally got the balls of
messenger I was nervous I didn't know
how she would respond you know and uh
she she emailed me back this morning and
it was real positive you know like
everything she had to say was real
positive and it's just
it's crazy man it's crazy you know
something I dreamed about my entire life
like every day
since I can remember during the of being
able to talk to my mother men and
uh she's going to give me a call this uh
this afternoon and we're going to talk
on the phone for the first time
it's crazy man it's been 32 years since
the last time I saw it you know so
I don't know exactly you know I text my
brother
my adopted brother and let him know and
then the next thing I did was I hopped
on the phone and gave you a call man I
don't you know I don't know exactly why
you know obviously we don't know each
other but
I just I wanted to share that with you
man daring brother
man thank you bro
thank you man this is uh
that's a nice as a pat it's just nice
you know it's nice that there's
something powerful going there's
something powerful going on in your life
and you thought and you
your nature whoever you are
you thought hey man I'm feeling
something there's really something
special going on I'm going to share it
with somebody else not even that it was
with me with this group uh
but this is a powerful moment I'm going
to share this with somebody else
um
that's awesome man thank you for the
call uh you got me up in here dog you
hit me in those man
my Chisholm James is a freaking
you got me in them damn
my little skied almonds these things are
activated oh
you know
it's funny man you
because you sound like you're in a good
place man this is just judgment from
this call
but you sound like you're in a good
place and
um
obviously your mother probably
isn't in the best place uh with jail
but
it sounds like you are gonna be able to
be there
you may have a chance to be for your
mother what she wasn't for you
which
and and that you may be strong enough to
do that
and that is
that's on God man I think
yeah I can't imagine you know waiting
your heart to talk to your mother God
you know all those times when you don't
even realize as a child as an offspring
as a creation of something that you need
that thing to be there
and not even sometimes their voice but
even just in their presence to know that
something is there
to support you like just like a wall
but like a wall that like loves you so
matter so so much no matter what
and a wall that's really also a door
um
man
but it sounds like you you
however your life has worked out that
you
sound healthy enough where you can you
might be able to be
whatever she never had in addition to
you guys working out your mother-son
relationship
um
and that's really that's that's what I
guess amazing about life it's like
what am I supposed to
how can I be useful in this situation
and me I don't know if I could do that
because I would probably look too much
at my own plight
I'd be looking too much at oh man my
mother this and I don't know if I'd be
able to turn that corner
and say honestly hey what is
why now are we back together and what
how do I look past my own
angst or my own you know or you may not
even have any more of that [__] but how
do I Rise Above That to be whatever
how do I be a great son and an adult son
you know I've had trouble evolving in
that way and evolving
from being just a son to being an an
adult son
um
that's funny this is kind of a space
that I'm in in my life but man I and I
didn't mean to talk about myself so much
it just it's powerful that you chose to
share that with us man
you know how good that makes us feel
first of all to have an urban guy call
Urban person that even [__] messes
with us bro
praise God dog
but even more than that just that
that you're like hey I I'm gonna I'm
gonna be
that you let all of us you let us enjoy
that moment with you
you let us in on that man you know how
much that is it's gonna give us
something
it's gonna give us a little bit more
faith that's going to get us through the
next day the next hour than that some
people just might be a minute but it's
going to give us something it gives me a
re we want to believe
that there's things out there that are
working for good
that's cool man so excited for you bro
uh if you get a chance man hit the
hotline again
um I'd just love to know how it went
you know
but if you are in that space where you
say hey man this is something powerful
and I'm going to call him a sheriff this
is I'm gonna let this be a part of this
Ambiance of this show
man that means a lot
and um yeah we'll connect and let me see
maybe there's something if there's
something nice we could do to help out
or help her I don't know uh
but somehow
even though even though it was giving
you up or what I don't know all I don't
know any of it
but shhh
she helped make a good son
you know she helped make a good son
somehow
um
so
man
you know this stuff I guess makes me
want to be alive
it makes me want to be alive
you know it's those moments man we use
[__] something you feel something
God that [__] is hot that is a high bro
that is a high bro
praise God baby thank you for calling in
um
I don't know I mean what you know what
else are we gonna say
um
uh uh yeah that's you know I feel like
it's just a good place to to finish the
show today this Show's been all over the
place I've been feeling all over the
place but that's okay I'm grateful to be
here with you guys
I'm grateful we're going to be adding
more we're going to try to get over to
England we got we're going to try to get
to everywhere
you know we're putting the shows out as
we can
um next week we'll have some new shows
going up in uh I think in St George Utah
or Springdale Utah
uh we're figuring some of that out if
you have a plan to be down there
um that'll be around uh the second week
of July second weekend
um let's go out the way that we didn't
even come in uh
uh we'll just close it out man
a lot of neat stuff uh I don't know what
else to say
uh maybe we've said enough
um
I don't know I feel like there's
something else I'm supposed to be
telling you guys but to all the people
out there struggling with these p with
the uh the stuff in the Midwest and the
fear and stuff like that is scary you
know it's scary to think that
um
that this template of the world we
sometimes we feel especially in America
like our environment that the world the
government all this is is going to take
care of us and when that doesn't happen
it's very scary because we realize we're
just this being in this in this
in this
template of society that we've created
and that if some of that structure fails
us or doesn't do us right we're still
sitting there responsible for ourselves
uh and that's very scary
so
my heart goes out to the people that are
in fear of that and uh
what else man oh man I don't know I've
been jerking off but
I don't want to be
so
it's been getting better
it's been getting better and that's all
we can ask oh you guys be good to
yourselves man
um you deserve it and we will let's go
out with some Bishop again
um
uh actually you know what let's go out
with some uh North Mississippi All-Stars
drunk Outdoors
let's do that man
um
this what a fun group to go see man
they're always torn if you get to check
them out and uh
[Music]
step outside
Outdoors
[Music]
and Lainey Wilson uh is dating someone
so I'm not trying to spread her news but
everybody's been asking me about it and
um
that's
that's that
[Music]